Hi, I'm Ramona J. Smith, Toastmasters
International 2018 World Champion of
Public Speaking. I know first hand how gestures
and body language. I know first-hand how gestures
and body language can help to captivate
an audience because I'm one of millions
of people who Toastmasters has helped gain the
confidence to communicate in all circumstances.
As a speaker, you know that the messages
your words convey can be helped or hurt by
the messages your body sends. To be truly
successful in communication, you must be
in command of your hand gestures, posture,
facial expressions, and overall body language.
Today, I'm going to share some great tips
that will help you master your movements.
Calm nerves with practice.
Have you ever been in front of an audience
and had trouble letting go of a lectern?
Nervous mannerisms can mean trouble for
speakers. For example, shifting your weight,
adjusting your glasses, wringing your hands.
These are all things you might do that lessen
the impact of your presentations and, oh!
Tugging at your clothes; that's a problem, too.
You'd be surprised how nervous tics and
inconsistent body language can distract
an audience. Gestures that don t coordinate
well with a speaker's message can drain the
speaker's energy and shift the audience's
focus away from the intended message.
So, what should a speaker do? The
answer is planning and practice.
The more you rehearse your speech, the better idea
you'll have for gestures that emphasize a point.
For example, if you want to explain to a group
that your new home is very far from your family,
you could extend one arm out from your
body while placing your other hand on your
heart to demonstrate the distance. This
descriptive gesture conveys the message
of distance while suggesting the idea
that your home is far from your heart.
Knowing that you're going to perform this
gesture at a targeted moment in your speech
will guide you as you prepare. When you
perform planned gestures in a speech,
you'll be able to channel nervous energy into
constructive movements that support your ideas.
Types of gestures
What kinds of
gestures should you imagine when planning a
speech? Think of them in four major groups.
First, descriptive gestures , like the one
I just used, help make your words clearer.
They can help describe things like the size,
shape, and location of objects you're discussing.
Second, emblematic gestures
are culturally specific,
though some are universal
such as nodding and shrugging.
Emblematic movements underscore strong
emotion such as earnestness and conviction.
In many cultures placing your hand on your heart
communicates a powerful belief in your message.
Third, representational gestures include movements
that give information about what you re doing.
You might use your hands to demonstrate
chopping, throwing, or picking something up.
And fourth, pantomime gestures are a good way
to ask your audience to participate or respond.
If you want them to raise their hands, for
example, you may raise your hand to show them.
Well, that's a lot of gestures, isn't
it? And that's good. For all the choices,
you can select those gestures that
naturally fit what you want to say.
Start by thinking about the ways you normally
move and try to rehearse those movements that come
naturally for you. If you feel you have to force
something that doesn't come from your instinctive
whole-body movements, think of another gesture or
movement that feels more natural to your style.
Movements such as this
are probably not expressive
enough to be in your speech. Instead, think of
gestures that support the ideas in your talk.
Try to focus your thoughts on the words
you share from one point to the next.
Consider movements that are a natural response
to your thoughts, feelings, and words.
A word of caution when planning your gestures.
Some gestures that are perfectly appropriate
in one culture are offensive in another. It's
important to know your audience and plan your
gestures
well.
Coordination
Coordinating gestures, eye contact, and
movement can be a challenge for any speaker.
When you present to an in-person audience, you
will need to practice making eye contact while
walking across a stage. It is another set of
skills entirely to coordinate gestures and
make eye contact while meeting fully online
or with virtual attendees and an in-person
audience during a hybrid meeting. Those skills
take time to develop in front of your webcam.
No matter how you meet in-person, fully online,
or hybrid take the time to practice with your
equipment or arrive early and walk around.
With your planned and rehearsed gestures,
you'll be able to let go of the lectern in no
time, and give your speech the impact it deserves.